reject nation we have made it to the
final episode of the book of boba fett
if you have been joining us on this
journey thank you so much for being here
use the force to hit that like button
and also big thanks to all who have
joined us on our patreon page so far
becoming super checks by checking out
all the content we got offer there full
length watch long as we sync up with the
time code for book of boba fett over at
patreon.com the real rejects lastly big
thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's see what theories come true last
few episodes have been pretty great so
far i'm so freaking excited let's do it
the palace offers greater protection if
you want to abandon moss espen hide in
your fortress go ahead we're staying
the people who live here need our
protection your mind's got purpose this
is your people now bubba
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
does fed have any other resources to
call upon
he used to live among a tuscan raider
tribe in the desert they no longer exist
we destroyed them ourselves does fed
know that he has no idea
he thinks they were killed by nikto
speed bikers
bastards
i think i have an idea how to draw boba
fett out oh no
[Music]
in the name of honor that was pretty
cool to see a whole scene with just
people and makeup yeah
how robert rodriguez is feeling
is he coming home
hello officer
got any power converters my new republic
certification seal tucked as you were
landing quite a coincidence if you ask
me
no
oh
so grand theft x-wing
grow group
the mandalorian he's not here
i don't know he's on the job of moses he
chose he's got that chain mail on kroger
whoa that's a terrible name
the way am i calling you that
your baby yoda you have here huh
something's shiny toads
there is someone here to see you
i thought you said nobody could sneak up
on us
oh no
i thought i smelled something
i don't negotiate
with gutless murderers if that's not the
quacker calling the stiffling slimy
i wouldn't be counting on the people of
freetown to be coming anytime soon
i paid marshall vancouver
i will only negotiate with the head of
the pike syndicate
you mean the one that massacred your
tuscan family and blamed it on a
speed-like game
let's do this
negotiations are terminated you're going
soft in your old age
we all do
god he's so creepy yeah i love that cat
cabbages here
that's a really good tent scene have the
pikes arrived not yet but something
feels off
oh no
oh
can trust you guys
[Music]
no oh no no best boys
yeah use those nuts come on
for opposition
nice
classic western
thank you
manners
i like it
manners maketh women on tattooing
manners make us mods
they're here
it was just a matter of time
with them
otherwise i don't want to go out there
okay then we'll both die in the name of
honor oh
sure you want to stay
this is the way god damn right it is
if i may offer an alternative make it
good
i will write out my statement and what
i'm willing to pay
i shall go as your emissary i have no
compunction whatsoever
genuflecting or even groveling dank
fair rick
i
boba fett
speaking as daimyo of the tatooine
territories formerly held by job in the
hutt do present the following offer
perhaps we should discuss what you'd be
willing to read
nothing
if you refuse these terms
arid sands of tatooine will once again
flourish with flowered fields fertilized
with the bodies of your death damn
you wrote all that boba fett
his words
oh cool hell yeah
strike
oh
nice
so cool
like butch cassidy at the sundance kid
[Music]
[Music]
now it'd be a great time for a little
backup
[Music]
free town
cool great shot
no
damn the cop really dies
i'm sorry about the marshall
gunned him down in cold blood
dang
[Music]
so look at the shininess of that paint
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] cool shot
honor among assassins
[Music]
oh [ __ ] damn it
wow
i like battle they're like the
santa menace battle droids have you seen
these shorts before they look familiar
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
[Laughter]
connect with it can you protect the
others i can distract them first though
why watch out
it's like a video game level yeah
boy
a bold move though man
earn back some cool points
[Music]
oh no oh no
be aware
[Music]
i thought she said the f word yep
[Music]
happy to see you too
i didn't know when i'd see you again
[Music]
but uh
we're in a bit of a bind here right now
be careful you keep your head down
you stay hidden until the fight's over
hey that's the shirt
you got the shirt
ouch
come on you can dismantle that thing
oh i totally forgot about that
[Music]
oh he's like a kai shoot
[Music]
that's pretty awesome
that's pretty awesome
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
oh no no no no no
nice work
yes
use the force young one
[Music]
get to work grogo
[Music]
hold its head up
do it
yeah
you defeated mecca godzilla
that's so awesome i love it so much
oh man that is so cool
it was literally just musing about
wishing for star wars
just don't let a door close on him
[Laughter]
no
no
[Music]
i am not a threat
nice head tails come on get behind me
pretty face holly's got you covered
hey what the hell's
oh wow you've earned it oh [ __ ] get off
that rancor
[Music]
so no fire
dang
this is my city
ah this isn't the first time i beat you
out on a job
there's no shame in it
look out for yourself
anything else
is weakness
oh yes yes yes
oh that's so cool
used the ways of the tuscan raiders to
defeat them
conflicted i love cabbie
[Laughter]
[Music]
so he's like king kong in this or
something huh yeah
bubba gotta come talk him down
hang on to this
it's gonna be okay a little stress ball
awesome
you're not my dad
don't worry kid your old man's crafty
spoke too soon
[Music]
oh my god no no no
don't worry can i
where'd you go kid
what
is he gonna do
are you a little badass
the rancor whisperer
oh
no buddy you are that of the new ruler
of tattooing
oh
damn
cruel killed robert rodriguez
i'm batman
damn
it's wonder where you went really are
the mvp you should take a nice soak in
the back to tank it's being used
huh we're starting
oh there they go cool shot
all right
but this is the last time
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey
so much more clearer now that it's all
come out
[Music]
it's red steering is a little cheesy to
me because you get
now that it's very clear yeah it's like
you didn't write any more lyrics
just repeating bubba fetter much better
than glitch bitterness
[Music]
it's thundercat in there
oh
cure him
[Laughter]
yes more advanced
oh that was bad i think that's gonna get
that see i'm gonna get a little picture
of it
i'll wind it back
that's cool yeah
i was like who's that generic white guy
that's the new thing boba's just taking
people in curing them
looks like nate's father on euphoria
from the side hit television series
euphoria yeah not enough dicks in this
episode of boba fett
dance who so
vance is going to get a mod upgrade yeah
i guess so i want to see his memory
special request by timothy oliphant
yeah
she was like not stopping this was just
a big ass fight once the action started
it's a big ass showdown there were times
where i was like is that john favreau
episode but there were so many shots so
i was like especially was walking
through the city oh okay like this feels
very el mariachi yeah yeah exactly
you can feel that austin texas sleeping
in all this
all righty
well here we are
um i got mixed feelings about a lot of
this because it's one of those episodes
that's like as an episode it's fine like
if there's a lot of really exciting
moments especially like when you isolate
certain scenes
they're they're very rewarding and
there's some really strong emotional
payoffs in a lot of ways like there's
definitely a lot of positives uh
throughout this episode and then
kind of factor in that we're telling the
the book of boba fett
and the story as it is as a whole for a
season
and that's where
i think a lot of my conflict with how i
feel about this finale sort of comes
from because like i said there's a lot
of positives that are truly exciting
stuff you know like i i loved the stuff
with grogu you know him showing up in
the x-wing was uh i was like whoa what
the hell was why luke here
yeah or at least r2 it looks like he
chose you
he says i'm dropping you off immediately
so that was a nice surprise it's cool
that luke let him have the x-wing to fly
back and i think you can set the x-wing
to some type of autopilot yeah to come
back yeah or or
you don't you know groggy didn't help
with that
yeah
so then uh you you could do that
and so that was a really nice moment
like everything with grogu honestly was
just so awesome that's it's funny
because like his his emotional beats
were so strong
and him reuniting with dinjaran too in
the middle of a battle i thought was
great this had so much of the classic
western vibes you know protecting a
small town and the way the
showdown ultimately unfolded
was uh reflective of many westerns but
doing it with a star wars style
and you know i i thought everything with
a rank or two was just awesome to behold
like it was it was like watching like
godzilla versus call you know
or pacific rim having that epic massive
kaiju type of flair to it and of course
seeing bobo riding the rancor making you
think of the holidays special in a lot
of ways but realizing it here was just
really awesome
and also you know like boba you have
finally
rockets and rocketing around jetpacking
around which was really fun and him and
mando side by side as well
uh was really great
you know and i like to i like the
exchanges there's there's things about
handling cad bane that i want to get
into
i like certain exchanges that happened
there
um
but the the the out the the end result
comes down to more than just some
nostalgia
like or love i would say for
cad bain it comes down to way more than
that because you gotta you gotta kind of
isolate it as it is as a season of
television and what they did and so
yeah yeah i feel like we're kind of on
the same page
i wish they had thought of it that way
sure yeah yeah sure and then boba
finally get like like i said there's a
lot of like great isolated moments the
post-credits thing uh it's it's cool to
see that cop anthony is alive because i
was like nah i should have wait for him
to just die and just yeah he's mentioned
it you know
hey you know it's it's off-screen you
know you never know true you know um
and and even with even with the way cat
bane died uh what i like is the
trajectory of the ark and and that's
where i think some of
i feel like this show would work best
if yeah if you watched only the boba
fett episodes of clone wars
and then when you watch this
then it's prayer like it is maybe his
episodes of mandalorian too you throw
that in there
and
but that not even really you need that i
feel like you need to watch those boba
fett episodes
and then you go and watch this so that
way you feel more of
what they're
implying with the ark to especially with
the fact that like cad main helped train
him and they did establish that
per their exchange here but like i said
if you haven't seen clone wars you
wouldn't be made privy to such a thing
you know you wouldn't know that and it's
kind of just a line that's mentioned
here
so when he does take him down i like
that he defeats him as the new version
of boba that he is now not through
the gunslinger fight
but through using the the tuscan raider
weaponry to take him down and win and
like i think that's cool and
representative of how he's changing who
he's who's embraced himself to be
uh at the same time though like with cad
bane
it's it what the my feeling is is that
you introduced him in the on the last
episode as this like oh [ __ ] there's
this new menacing threat who's come to
like they give him an entrance yes
you know
he is this menacing threat just walking
in the desert like i'm just gonna walk
my way through this desert i'm gonna
kill some people
and i'm gonna turn around as low as i
want to and relish every word yeah and
then
he doesn't really do much in this
episode when you think about it he like
kind of intim tries to intimidate boba
then he has this brief fight with him
and then he's just dead yeah
and so it's like on two levels like oh
that's a bummer we just got cad bane
back and they totally treated the last
episode with that level of nostalgia
love of cat beans in live-action form
isn't that exciting
so let's say you eliminate that
now it's just okay the cad maiden
character i've never seen clone wars
let's just watch this oh they really
hyped this guy up i guess it kind of
resulted in like a 30 second fight with
some monologue either and it was kind of
like the end of it you have no other
context it's kind of like the original
boba fett portion
he shows up he looks really cool and
then he gets taken out pretty easily
see what dawned on me and it was kind of
early on in the episode
was when mod girl
the whatever her name is the i don't
know
something the main mod girl was like no
we can't go back to your palace
we have to stay here and fight this is
my city
and boba's like this is yeah it will
stay in my city too it really hit me in
that moment that i'm not as invested in
this
as i would like to be
this is not something that i think as a
season they've really built up to well
because i haven't got to experience at
all
how the pikes being here
have affected the people
we haven't seen like man they're really
they're real
yeah
like oh man this place was a great
delicious amazing people yeah yeah you
couldn't shove the tyranny of the pikes
maybe at all i mean like yeah they wiped
out the tuscans and they blamed it on
the biker gang but even that is like way
more specific to boba fett and removed
from everybody else on top yes like i
gotta see yeah like we got to see them
like mess up like uh wipe out the tuscan
raiders sure and like you said just very
just spotlight on bobo for that moment
but in terms of like my city and what
the pikes are really capable of doing
you know i'm like well the tuscan
raiders were
not the size of a city
so i don't really know what what it is
their influence is doing that's so bad
and i never got to have a scene where
i'm like
wow this is really affecting me i hate
the place
yeah or even for cad bane other than him
shooting koban
other than that one scene of like man
they really built this guy up yeah and i
didn't really get to see just how much
of a of an ultimate threat he is
and it's like
you know some somebody argue like well
that's why you got to watch clone wars
and sure
but even with that i'm like well if i
just watch clone wars i'd be bummers i'm
like we just brought him back now he's
dead yeah
yeah
it's not much of a of a true payoff in
that regard and so i think as a season
as a whole i didn't
really feel like i got to know who boba
is
and i did and fennec was kind of like
the mvp and so many things and i felt
like i didn't really really get to know
who she is either
like they
they have the thing with the pikes
killed the tuscans and they do the
flashbacks because it's been so long to
spend time
so they do the flashbacks
and then
fennek ends up off in them
yeah shouldn't that be like a boba
moment shouldn't that be like boba's
revenge yeah there's a lot that should
feel a lot more personal in a lot of
these transactions of violence i think
what was missing for me is while there
was a lot of excitement and while
there's a lot of entertainment
that i really did enjoy don't get me
wrong i'm not just saying that to be
nice like i was a there's a lot i had a
lot of fun with
not so much as strong early on in the
fight scenes
um
but later on i started really getting
into it a lot
it's the
it's uh i feel like there's a i like
weirdly a lack of soul is the way i
would put it
yeah yeah yeah there's a lack of
resonance or a lack of real meat to get
invested in everyone's motivation it's
like boba fett shows up
and after this experience with the
tuscans he bonds with the the place
and then for the rest of the time he's
just kind of saying you know like this
is my you know these are my people this
is my town this is my planet now
but there's no really yeah we don't
really get any kind of real investment
into what that means what emotional
experiences cause that what challenges
are actually
at their feet in terms of establishing
some kind of order mitigating between
all the different families like we see
him talk to you we see a bunch of like
political debates but it's like you said
we don't really ever go and have
any personal time with the people of
espa or the other surrounding areas the
way we do with the tuscan it feels like
the most development happened
all in the flashbacks and everything in
the present is sort of like very just
straightforward no i've decided this is
my town so everyone should respect that
and they're not respecting it so i guess
we have to fight and while i well we
liked episode three more than pretty
much the population of planet earth yes
we liked it more than most people
i was had a lot of faith that they were
still building up to something
gratifying and really interesting
and like the let's just cut face facts
or the mandalorian [ __ ] those two
episodes of mando and the story lines
derived from there had easily been the
best part of of this season
and i really liked the flashback episode
like episode two and four i thought were
really great really strong stuff
um never reached quite the emotional
heights of the mandalorian episodes and
so my thinking is is okay if you're
gonna
do two episodes in your series that
about book like where you're building up
building up building up and then you're
gonna put that story on hold
but really put the brakes on that
shift all your focus to mandalorian 2.5
then you can't just do one more episode
like you got to have a couple more
episodes i feel like the show treated it
like they really built up to this
climactic finale
but i'm like i i feel like we just
started learning like the bike just
showed up and now we're here yeah i feel
like there are two episodes worth of
stuff happening on tatooine that we
literally just didn't watch
in order to watch the dinjara story and
hey i'm not complaining that that's
there at all but it does
it does seem as though that it feels
like instead of having all the
mandalorian 2.5 stuff be complementary
to the boba fett story overall
it really does feel
like oddly structured in a way where
this feels like a big setup to explain
why anytime we go back to tatooine boba
will be there it's like sort of what
this feels like in this moment of like
okay and mantos season three will
probably check in with him from time to
time or something and and they don't
really the way they do resolution at the
end
uh didn't feel like much of a payoff and
felt really corny
you know like they just they walk
together there's black croissant and
there's [ __ ] uh the mod gang and like
i really felt like i didn't get to know
anybody and i did i really didn't feel
like
at the end of the day that's that's kind
of my issue is i feel like i just
started scratching getting to know
people
and now
i feel
like my cup is have very half full on my
connection with all these new people
yeah you know because you get all these
interesting introductions but then yeah
you don't get any character beats with
any of them so then by the end in the
big battle it's sort of just like all
these western archetypes you're used to
seeing of people who aren't willing to
be pushed around any longer and even
with the like i
i like the mod gang a lot more than most
people as a part of this show as a sort
of kooky detail but that especially the
the sort of lead female mod who's doing
most of the you know
talking in this episode who is sort of
the most spot lit in this episode feels
sort of like a different character from
where we picked them up
the first time and i feel like all that
grit like we picked them up and they're
like you know tagging stuff and they're
clearly like a gang of some kind who's
not on the up and up and it feels like
none of that
carries to the end and so you know you
have this political situation you have
these desperate people but you don't
really get the circumstances of their
desperation beyond lip service and it's
interesting to me because you know it's
a lot of the same creative team as the
mandalorian and yet a lot of the
complaints people had about the
mandalorian you know moving really slow
and not actually doing much with that
time as much as i i like
this series and i liked
probably each episode more than the sum
of all the parts together it does feel
like a lot of those complaints people i
would hear apply to the mandalorian i
would more aptly apply to this it's like
you have a lot of really cool imagery
and a lot of really cool setups but
ultimately it doesn't feel like we went
very far with any of them and there's a
bunch of stuff that's introduced and
then that happens off screen
that gets you know these payoff moments
in a finale like this but yeah that
don't ring past the initial in the
moment experience of watching it it's
like i i i feel like robert rodriguez
has gotten a lot of crap for the series
particularly for his episodes and and
i've liked all of his episodes to some
degree i had maybe gripes about the
first one but this one even i thought
was like really fun and really thrilling
uh but yeah just at the same time it
feels like they didn't actually have as
fleshed out of a plan for doing this as
its own series as it felt like they did
at the start
no
no not in as much of an evocative tone
either no it's like all the parts are
there and i feel like you don't have to
make boba fett the same character as
dinjar and a lot of people like why
wasn't the mandalorian just boba fett
like you can have this more stoic
silent character who does just want to
you know go on the up and up and you
know clean up tattooing whatever that is
but i don't know we have to yeah feel
the urgency of that motivation too
and so when he's asking him like what's
your line you know like what's your
motivation for doing this i'm still not
sure yeah that's what i mean it is like
because i don't want to pay you watch
idiots deal with this yeah i'm like i
don't i feel like you're really
connected to tuscan raiders but you keep
saying like this is my city and stuff
but we never really saw you connect with
with this planet we never really saw
your true connection to it and since the
tuscans are kind of
sequestered away from everybody too that
almost adds an extra layer of okay
why all the other people then who aren't
with the people that you spent so much
time with that had these formative
moments and you think there'd be some
payoff with him having a moment to like
honor the tuscans
in some way because he finds the truth
out yeah yeah either be something there
i don't know what it like putting up
something in the city that honors the
tuscany yeah yeah yeah yeah
whatever yeah some kind of tuscan
monument or something a way of honoring
them because yeah i didn't feel any like
cathartic reward with his story when it
came to i kept feeling like they're
building up to something and i really
felt like i grew to love boba by the end
of episode like by the time we were like
on three or four i was like i really
love this guy if it's the flashback
stories who he is in present day he's
kind of a boring character
yeah because he's present he's kind of
born he's pretty boring yeah and and
it's funny because as much as i'm with
him and i like that character i too was
like i feel like you gotta make a
statement to all these other people
because all you do in most of these
scenes is you walk in you tell people
you're lying you know like you you be
neutral when the tusk's gonna show up
can you do that
yeah okay cool and that's that's it like
there's no
even debate
there he just kind of says his piece and
then people are like okay fine and then
they don't follow through on it and
that's not really as intense as you know
i feel like they they bothered to have
like the major domo and the mayor and
they have all these political pieces and
there's almost no political
situation dealt with at all
no no not at all it's like the pikes
always show up in these likes
real isolated moments yeah and then the
main pike's just chilling in his little
fan cave you know
she's always there waiting on words
yeah it really lacked uh i kept feeling
like they were building up to something
out and i guess i was more i really
wanted to love this episode especially
after
really like three
great episodes back to back
for
being like my personal favorite and then
from the boba fett from the first four
episodes
and while i think there's an argument we
made that twos probably
before
before it was my personal favorite i had
the most connection to
and then five was fantastic and then six
was awesome
and then
this one i was like i really just didn't
want to let go of that love
yeah and then i just found it kind of
like sort of slipping yeah and and then
like oh you're kind of getting me back
uh i never it doesn't quite reach the
heights i wanted you to hit by the end
so the action in the beginning was
really off to me
like i thought i liked the scene there's
a lot of cool action don't get me wrong
there's a lot of really cool action from
like a lot of really cool moments and
shots
some of that robert rodriguez cheese
that i i do like like him like
yeah put them on the carts and the cart
toppling over and all that stuff like i
like some of the cheesy rod rodriguez
like once upon a time in mexico
desperado types of [ __ ] fighting
scenes i think those are fun
um and then getting to see how he like
all that cgi effects that he's become
more well well acquainted with
you know things like spy kids 4d uh or
so it's just fighting for one doesn't
matter but uh
lost souls or whatever is that two oh
yeah probably right spike his spike is
3d and then there's a four that no one
really saw yeah and then uh then there's
uh you know lead a battle angel it's
like i thought he captured the stuff
with the rancor really well like that
was really exciting would i like to have
seen him bomb with the rancor a little
bit
i mean granted it did work on me because
i'm gonna go help i was
but one shot did they're
shot down by one of those droids sure
that
so uh yeah when uh the raincore shows up
would like to see them bomb with it so
like those those fight scenes were cool
but then some of the there was just some
moments i can't really recall them right
now especially with black or scientific
i was like what is this fight scene
oh yeah where they're all like oh
they're just tackling him yeah yeah that
was a bit kooky i'd be i i thought the
action was i know everybody points to in
that but like even black chrysanthemum
though man like they don't really like
didn't get as much of a moment as he
could have just like he seemed like they
were building up there and then they
don't
you don't get that catharsis that you
that you think they're going to where
it's like the ultimate tying the
storylines together i'm like i feel like
there's a whole chapter from the book of
pope it's missing i feel like several
pages fell out and then somebody hastily
crammed some mandalorian pages in there
just to pat it out like yeah it does
feel like stuff is is missing and it's
so strange to me that it should feel
that way especially when i i felt like
okay we're deviating we're doing these
two
star wars overall and also mandalorian
heavy episodes there has to be a reason
purpose for doing so and and from where
i'm sitting it really doesn't feel like
it and i don't know i'm i'm very taken
aback by that oddly like i think i think
this story feels more necessary
to watch the dinjar and stuff
and i'm like i don't really feel like
it's that unless you want to get some
facts about how boba's alive
you know you don't it doesn't really
feel it and i where i feel especially
let down
is fennec shan more than anything else
she gets nothing additional she's not
she's not a person really she's this
she's really like the one who seems to
she's just cool she seems to call the
shots yeah more often she seems like she
does most of the business she's the
straightforward pragmatic one who knows
how this [ __ ] works and she's not but
she's not much of a and as as badass as
she is
makes me kind of question what happened
with her in chapter five of season one
gunslinger
i'm like damn how did your ass get taken
down
because i see you just show up and like
everyone's like oh my god they're
shooting us from everywhere yeah
she's everywhere yeah she shows up she
breaks through the pike tent
ninja batman's her way in there i've
completely forgotten about her by that
point too yeah
she's not she's not really a character
and uh and their relationship her boba
doesn't really grow beyond
the surface of both of those characters
they're like stoic avatars by the end
they're like avid like game characters
you select just to have some cool that's
to do the fighting but you don't really
feel like
yeah there's a lack of an emotional
payoff respect like like you were
talking about the campaign scene that
was like some of the most emotion
boba showed yeah um yeah
still
but but that moment is undercut when
you're like oh he's dead now he we're
going to kill him now
so this is the problem with the episode
is like most of its action yeah which
should feel like super rewarding and
it's exciting and entertaining but when
you're breaking down the story
it feels a little lackluster well that's
the thing is
for me just looking back on this here
and now i feel like
the the writing to me is what has let
this season down the most i mean again i
know
of all the directors robert rodriguez
gets the most sort of uh [ __ ] for some
of the choices he's made this episode
especially i thought from beginning to
end i was pretty much pulled in there
maybe one or two fight scenes that felt
a little wonky but for the most part i
thought it was really punchy really
beautiful designs as always but yeah
just like
here and now with everything it feels
like the writing of this season was
really like
undercooked or something it just doesn't
feel like the same group of people wrote
this as wrote the mandalorian and yet
they did
you know nah yeah i felt like they just
made it really fast yeah it feels like
they they wrote it really fast and they
didn't either
you know finally put a lot of tlc into
those mandalorian episodes
they did and i i'm so i guess that in
the long term i'm sure that's what's
most important because
unless there's a second season of boba's
but they don't get you anything to be
excited about for the future well no and
the thing is by the end you want or i
was hoping that you know all these
ragtag players we have a mass between
boba and fennec and chris santan and you
know their little consortium the mods
you want to feel like there's some kind
of fully realized team
and and maybe even have some kind of
yeah cathartic moment where it's like uh
yeah we prevailed and and i don't
begrudge at the the flip side of that
where it's like we barely made it
through this
uh but at the same time yeah they just
feel kind of like a a bunch of people
who could easily split up now that this
is done and uh you know i don't know
i wanted to feel like there was a
greater sense of purpose and i don't
mind things that are anecdotal or or you
know slice of life even not that's
really a good adjective for any of this
but but it doesn't yeah feel
it feels like they directed this to be
something deeper than it actually is
oh well
i feel like maybe if this was a cartoon
i would have less to complain about
or something but
yeah
maybe
but then again i don't know like the the
various anime shows are beloved for some
of their
episodes man um the [ __ ] last season
of clone wars is some of the most
intense [ __ ] i've ever seen from star
wars i'm like on the like that last year
i'm like on the edge of my seat uh
yeah that is um yeah well i'm a little
i'm kind of pretty disappointed in a lot
of ways but then this the show of
weirdly this this show
also gave me some of the most memorable
star wars moments ever and uh like
episode
five it's just so funny how both of them
couldn't complete their training as
fandom and gregory because they were so
distracted by their longing
together yes
but uh yeah other than like the ninja
art stuff is perfect i'm [ __ ] hella
excited for mandalorian season three but
if you were to announce book of boba
fett season two i'd be like
uh i got a different uh different main
director to helm please or get some just
take some variety
maybe draft these scripts uh all with
one idea in mind why do we have a pen
that make to make this [ __ ] go longer
yeah it's weird i i almost felt like you
should have more time to hammer that
stuff out and coordinate it all and yet
it felt like somehow all these were
written like like they all got a brief
on what the general idea of the season
was and then all of a sudden they were
written in a vacuum separately from each
other so they all feel like they kind of
match but
not in any like really synergistic way i
don't know go yell at kathleen kennedy
yeah i ruined star wars
somehow they'll say this is like woke
mobbed crap and i'm like all right yeah
man there's two women when they went on
the roof to fight girls get it done the
whole episode was about that too woke
guys what'd you think about this
and uh we will catch you guys soon
thank you for being here on this journey
with us regardless um
i
it's so strange because like
yeah i liked
i liked all the episodes the other one
that i felt was a little bit empty to me
was episode one and i was like i'm
willing to just wait and then
sometimes it's fine you're like that's
weird that was one of the most exciting
i was like the most that was a really
like it aimed to be exciting
action-packed finale and yet i somehow
felt
disappointed as a story
so
you gotta have those character
motivations locked down
all right guys
we'll talk with you soon
[Music]